james o'keefe once again embarrassing
cnn
apparently a cnn staffer went on five
tinder dates
with a a spy from project veritas
according to mediaite
say james o'keefe's project veritas has
just released new secretly recorded
footage on tuesday that reveals cnn
employees describing how the network
worked
to support joe biden's campaign during
the 2020 election shocker
cnn technical director charlie chester
played the video's starring role
here is some of charlie chester talking
about the the role of cnn
in uh in the 2020 election
they've already announced inner office
that
once the public is
will be open to it we're going to start
focusing mainly on climate um
uh climate like global warming and
like that's gonna be our next like um
i don't know like
it's gonna be our focus like uh like our
focus was to
get trump out of office right without
saying that that's what it was right
so our next thing is gonna be for
climate change awareness they're
just uh and of course this is all
obvious
this is all obvious i mean it's clear
that cnn is a propaganda outlet we've
all known this for a long time
it's just that they lie and then when
you call them on it they're like how
dare you they get brian stelter on
reliable sources
yelling about fox news or something okay
the most damning portion of the video is
that opening
supercut the footage didn't make the
identity of chester's conversational
partner clear
the rack of liquor bottles is clearly
pictured behind him in one scene
chester said that his role is one step
down from director
though the role of technical director
has no input on the contents of any
programming but he
has suggested there is sort of internal
communication suggesting what the
mission was
chester says quote trump was his hand
was shaking he was losing it
he's unfit we were creating a story
there i think that's propaganda
apparently he was talking there he would
imagine about the trump picking up a
glass of water with both hands
we had nothing else to run with at that
time we were like just taking shots off
about just hoping something would hit
you know
his conversational partner a woman tells
him at one point she has a confession
about her concerns with biden
she says he has i guess i have a
confession i worry about biden in his
health i guess
yeah i just want to take care of him
make sure he's okay chester said that
was precisely the kind of concern the
network worked to assuage during the
campaign chester said the whole thing of
him running showing him jogging was
obviously deflection of his age they're
trying to make it like okay i'm healthy
he said we'd all should always show
shots of him jogging like i'm healthy
and blah blah blah
chester also said he'd be okay with it
if kamal harris became president chester
said
i had so many arguments about my my dad
would be like you know you're voting in
kamala harris he's going to die in the
presidency
and i'm like he's not going to effing
die but i'm okay with that i'm okay with
that
she could probably be a real b word in
like a board meeting and you'd hate her
as a boss but she's having real
and better than what we got regardless
so um also he uh he basically
acknowledged openly
that they craft their coverage around
narrative
if the agenda say is to like get
like matt gates right now he's like he's
republican
uh he's a problem for the democratic
party because he's so
conservative and he can cause a lot of
hiccups
in passing applause so
it's it would be great
so we're going to keep running those
stories to keep hurting him
and make it so that he can't be buried
and like just
you know settled outside of court and
just like you know if we keep
pushing that it's helping us
that's propaganda it's helping us in
some way
okay but here is the thing most
journalists don't even have
the insight that charlie chester the cnn
technical director does
margaret sullivan writes an awful column
for the washington post in which she
basically just pretends
that partisan journalism is in fact
objective journalism she has a piece
today
in which she says ask almost any group
of journalists to name the core values
of their profession
and they'll probably probably deliver a
list like this oversight
we're the watchdogs keeping an eye on
government officials and other powerful
people and institutions
transparency we believe it's best to put
information out in the open not keep it
hidden
factuality it's crucial to provide as
much accurate information as possible to
get to the truth
spotlighting wrongdoing we think
society's problems are best solved by
exposing them to public criticism
giving a voice to the voiceless it's our
job to advocate for those lacking power
or social standing
these ideas are so ingrained we have
adopted certain aphorisms to express
them
sunlight is the best disinfectant
comfort the afflicted and inflict the
comfortable we cancel each other
okay but um here is the problem they are
liars
just like all self-reported surveys if
you ask people how often do you exercise
people always answer that they exercise
a lot more than they actually do
if you ask people how wonderful they are
they will always tell you they are
unbelievably great
journalists may say that they care about
oversight and keeping an eye on
government officials meanwhile
they're just like why are we even asking
tough questions of joe biden we should
stop this
transparency that it's they believe it's
best to put information out in the open
weird because i seem to remember this
hunter biden story where you all cheered
on full-scale suppression of an actual
story
factuality you have to give as much
information as possible to get to the
truth
weird because i see like stories every
single day where you don't give as much
information as possible particularly
when it comes to policing
spotlighting and wrongdoing you think
that society's problems are best solved
by exposing them to public
weird because you were defending andrew
cuomo all of last year giving a voice to
the voiceless
well it seems like mostly you care about
giving a voice to the people you want to
give a voice to and shutting everybody
else up
but put that aside according to margaret
sullivan our values can be a turn-off
for the general public
it suggests that journalists who want to
reach the broadest audience and have the
greatest impact
should consider changing the way they
think about their present work
the study a new way of looking at
trusted media is from media insight
project
it builds on research led by social
psychologist jonathan height
researchers asked participants how much
they support the values i mentioned
above transparency
factuality but kept it in the abstract
without specifying a focus on journalism
the results indicate that only one out
of the five core values touted by
journalists
shares the support of a majority of
americans about seven in 10
people support the idea that we should
pursue facts that get us closer to the
truth
the value drawing the least support is
that the good way to make society better
is to spotlight its problems
only about three and ten agree well that
is at least partially understandable
considering that maybe the way to make a
good society better is to uphold its
strengths as well as spotlighting its
problems maybe a lot of people
see your spotlighting its problems as a
way of tearing down the system which is
what you guys overtly say you want to do
only about one in 10 americans fully
support all five of the journalism
values tested
people who prize loyalty and authority
are much like much less likely than
others to see the need for a watchdog
over the powerful
people who put a high value on fairness
are more likely to think society should
amplify the voices of those
lacking power so of course this means
that the real reason the real reason
that people don't trust the media is
because
it is the people who are wrong we cannot
be bad at any of this
it is the people who are wrong or
alternatively
you suck at this and all the things you
say you prize you don't actually prize
and the american people know it i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the ben
shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content